in the 1950s it first became sort of
clear that rockets were actually
sufficiently advanced that we were
maybe going to get to space people
started to worry what will happen when
alien biospheres collide planetary
quarantine became the planetary
protection which became
uh international law and it encompasses
two different strands so one is ford
contamination that's bringing earth life
to extraterrestrial environments a
couple of reasons for this one uh earth
life might wipe out alien life and also
it might just make it really hard to
know if we found alien life for bringing
life with us there's also back
contamination and that is when we are
bringing
samples or people back from
extraterrestrial environments now this
became an issue during the apollo
missions
and so it involved the cdc sort of
officially said hey you're not bringing
the astronauts back unless they go into
quarantine
and nasa said oh well we didn't think
there was life on the moon so we weren't
planning that and had to scramble so
they retrofitted an airstream trailer
put the astronauts and the lunar samples
in it
brought them back to houston where they
had constructed the lunar receiving lab
essentially a quarantine facility
and then they declared a federal
quarantine there to prevent the risk of
contaminating earth with
extraterrestrial life which is the only
time there's been a quarantine against
extraterrestrial life in the federal
register
and then you know
eventually realized there was no need
for that there was no life on the moon
but what's interesting about this is if
quarantine is about uncertainty
then planetary quarantine is sort of a
fractal example of uncertainty we have
no idea
if there is life elsewhere in the
universe and if so if it poses a danger
to earth life we have no idea if earth
life would pose a danger to it or even
if earth life would be capable of
replicating in extraterrestrial
environments